- Speaking of girls night out, I have to say,
this is one of my best moments of my life.
I've had a few times that
I've randomly run into her
and like, pretended it was totally normal.
And I was with Reba and they were like
we're going to this dinner,
and I'm like, all of a
sudden, like you're there,
and I'm just like, yeah,
it's totally normal.
And I'm like, it matters to me.
I'm like, I'm like
totally wanting to sing.
Do you remember this night though?
This is one of, do you remember?
- [Guest] Yes.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly Clarkson] I went to
go see Shania. You did too.
I was with Reba, and I was like,
I was pretending, I was,
I was Meryl Streep right there.
I was like, so chill about it.
But like legit was so excited.
- Same.
Like, my friends afterwards,
we were just like,
do you remember how I
pretended that was normal?
Yeah. I was very excited about that night,
but I was wondering,
cause we just were talking
about girls nights out,
do you do that with your daughters?
Do you ever say Tim, you're not allowed
and you just go?
- [Guest] It just happened.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It just happened?
What'd y'all do?
- Yeah.
- Well, he,
he was not allowed because
he was actually working.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh. That's
a good time to do it, though.
'Cause then you don't feel as bad.
You're like, well you're working.
It's your fault.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's one way to look at it I guess.
Gracie, our oldest, we
have three daughters.
- Yeah.
- Gracie just turned 25 last week.
- Wow.
- Last week, yes.
- Yeah.
- This week,
and we went on a girl's trip,
and have the best time
the four of us together,
and Gracie's best friend.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Girl, I'm all about the dancing.
- Oh, I love dancing.
- Now, I cannot dance at all,
and I'll be the first to admit it.
I know I can't dance, but I do not care.
I don't care.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It, should be whatever
it should be, though.
It's like, it feels good
just to move your body.
- [Guest] I, you know, it
should be whatever it should be.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- That's when people go, mhmm.
- [Kelly Clarkson] No,
you know what they say?
They're like, look, I just went
to a concert trail and obtain
this lady in the front.
I was like one, what are you on ma'am?
And two, she was living her best life,
and it was beautiful to watch.
Like she was just so into
it moving and it feels good.